you're from is this right you're from
Yardley puzzle yeah in Bucks County
that's like a little house just like a
small town it's a small town but we have
some notable residents my favorite our
most famous criminal of all time in
criminal I like I thought you were gonna
say well Jimmy Stewart's from there and
we went right to criminal yeah I like
that and there's this guy from my town
called the bread molester what yeah and
he would go into grocery stores and he
would go to the bread aisle and he would
just take bread and just squeeze it
because he like he loved the way bread
felt yielding under his hands and then
all the grocery stores installed because
he was doing this to so many grocery
stores just ruining the bread like he
would go to buy their bread and it had
been pretty good ya big freak lipstick
[Applause]
and you draw the shades come to me my
sweet little ride yeah it's it's
disturbing but if you said that they
started the they started to put kids in
a sting operation cuz they all these go
sisters to each other they caught got to
catch the bread ran a stop well they did
they caught him and then he defended
himself in court and he destroyed so
much bread that it was a felony level
destruction of property and he went to
jail and I can't even imagine like in
jail where they're like like what are
you in for like manslaughter
what are you in for I find the texture
of dough you're resist
[Laughter]
you